[Musique]
bonjour bertrand françois lubin bonjour
universitaire ainsi les endroits publics
après demain le vote
les martiniquais commençons à désigner
leurs députés nous verrons l'aspect
technique de cette élection avec vous
mais pour commencer c'est quand trois
candidats en lice dans les quatre
circonscriptions martinique est ce
vraiment un record pour ce type
d'élection dans notre île alors je n'ai
pas en tête les deux les chiffres des
élections présidente mais en tout cas ce
qu il convient donc de noter c'est que
la martinique participe à un mouvement
global puisque ce phénomène s'observe au
niveau national puisque on recense pour
les élections donc de dimanche pas moins
de 7000 787 1882 candidats ce qui vous
présente une moyenne de 14 candidats par
circonscription
et puis si on me ceci en parallèle avec
nos amis guadeloupéens où il ya 80
personnes et qu'est ce qui peut
justifier le thème tel succès pour cette
élection là alors je sais pas si on peut
parler de succès mais en tout cas je
pense qu'il ya un argument de principe
il faut d'abord mettre en avant celui
donc l'argument démocratique la
démocratie posthume que tout un chacun
des locaux ont rempli les conditions
posées par les textes qu'on puisse se
présenter
et puis par ailleurs je pense que cet
afflux donc deux candidats s'explique
surtout banques dans le contexte d'un
conjecture actuelle en uc à la défiance
que l'on peut observer à l'endroit de la
classe politique
donc on regarde cette défiance chacun
vous êtes très gentil et très possible
ce fut le cas il ya beaucoup de gens qui
se disent aussi gars tous à la jambe en
effet plus un papa franck ou supports
possibles mais bon je bouge je m'attache
pas politiques mènent des politiques
lorsqu'il voit certains de leurs
collègues à lille le 10 1 c'est fort
probable mais je peux faire porter
l'accent sur des arguments qui ne sommes
plus plus objectif
en tout cas on peut aisément constater
que dans ce contexte de défiance que
tout un chacun estime qu'il serait
peut-être mieux à même de faire par
rapport à ce qui c'est qui ton post
alors lorsqu'on regarde
une telle quantité de candidats pour par
circonscription mécaniquement forcément
il y aura des conséquences sur le sur le
vote
au delà de ligne et semant des suffrages
alors la conséquence
oui l'abstention on peut présumer une
forte abstention à l'occasion à
l'occasion donc de cette élection
ce qui risque donc d'avoir une
conséquence majeure ce que nombre de
candidats peut-être ne pourront pas se
présenter au second tour puisque vous
avez cet écueil de à 12,5 pour cent qui
conditionne la possibilité donc de ceux
présents à leur grand tour et pourrait
être élue dès le premier talent pour
être élu au premier tour il faut remplir
deux conditions la majorité absolue donc
soit 50% des voix plus une
face à la majorité absolue est par
ailleurs pour des raisons de roy
présente ativités il faut que cette
personne ou accueille un cas en termes
de voix un quart donc 2 des suffrages
exprimés
dix mois des inscrits ouais donc ça
c'est très simple pour le premier tour
et pour finir second tournant pour
figurer au second tour il faut que les
candidats effectivement obtiennent 12 5%
des voix
d'accord ce qui constitue avec ta bécane
dans un contexte abstentionniste dirty
rich man devra aller surtout vers des
duels pas de triangulaire pas de pas de
second tour à quatre candidats ce sera
les clients güller ou encore les quatre
gangs eu l'air sont possibles parce que
ça a déjà existé mais cela suppose
effectivement une mobilisation assez
forte de la part
des électeurs et cette hypothèse s'il y
a une forte mobilisation cette hypothèse
est possible compte tenu de
l'émiettement du paysage politique
allemand vous ressentez les choses il
doit y avoir une forte mobilisation pour
ce scrutin de samedi n'ont à vrai dire
je ne crois pas regard de ce que
j'entends hausse que de ce que je sais
je ne pense pas que la grille de salaire
de de ce pouvoir attractif de du salaire
du député est ce que quelque part les
affaires les affaires qu'on a qu'on a pu
voir ces derniers temps est ce que
quelque part ça n'a pas finalement
dégoûter les lecteurs oui toute une
série de 20 épisodes wii et toute une
série de facteurs
l'éditorial de jeu manque parti en a
fairy tale je pense qu'effectivement que
dernier argument qu'il a évoquée c'est
la lassitude parce qu'effectivement dans
cette campagne a commencé fort longtemps
donc il ya la lassitude a ajouté platini
qui entre en 2015 désagréments des
affaires l'institut de vienne pluralité
donc de facteurs qui expliquent
effectivement que probable absent une
probable absence y ont donc à l'occasion
donc de ces élections
donc on votera ici en martinique les 10
et 17 juin prochains les députés feront
crois pas de vacances en tout cas pas
tout de suite pour eux alors après we
know je crois alors si normalement le
parlement travaille à l'occasion d'une
session ordinaire do kids qui dure
d'octobre à fin juin bon - effet ce te
ment à la demande du premier ministre le
président l'a public va prendre un
décret convoquant les futurs députés en
session extraordinaire qui aura lieu au
cours du mois de cours du moins donc de
juillet en vue de faire adopter le
projet de loi d'habilitation pour qu'il
puisse prendre ses fameuse ordonnance
visant à réformer le code du travail
donc les députés issus des urnes du du
week end du 17 et 18 juin vont se rendre
à l'assemblée nationale à une date pas
encore fixé soit adoptée par rapport au
conseil par le président aulas publie
mais il y aura tout un rituel il va
falloir désigner le président de la ce
en version d'essai lors de cette
fectivement donc cette réunion je dirais
inaugural on va procéder à l'élection du
président du bureau ainsi de suite et
pendant donc cette session on va surtout
donc de de donner au gouvernement au
président de la république est
directement
la possibilité de réformer le code du
travail mais par voie dans l'eau dans sa
requête c'est quoi la différence entre
une ordonnance à 49,3 pas la langue
si vous voulez le ordonnance alors le
terme ordonnance à deux sens dans le
langage juridique en premier par
françois 1er le jeu présente ainsi en
premier lieu dans le monde judiciaire
c'est une décision rendue par un juge
unique notamment quand il ya urgence
médard à circonstances dans le cas
d'espèce c'est le les ordonnances donc
ce sont des mesures prises par le
gouvernement dans le domaine de la loi
en d'autres termes les ré certaines
règles doivent nécessairement en pointe
et la voix l'islate yves ouais mais pour
des raisons de temporalité je dirais le
gouvernement une urgence de situer le
gentil vervinois là c'est exactement le
cas le gouvernement donc demande
en d'autres termes au parlement de se
dessaisir à son profit et donc il va
falloir donc on adopte au cours de cette
session extraordinaire un projet de loi
d'habilitation où il sera indiqué les
ordonnances qui sont adoptées par le
gouvernement une fois qu'il sera
habilité par le parlement et donc deux
semaines dans cette main dans ce même
projet de loi va figurer nécessairement
le délai qui sera accordée au
gouvernement pour prendre ces
ordonnances à ce que ça peut être un
mois deux mois trois mois la pimpante
prêt jusqu il va falloir la suisse est
dans le temps 9-3 tout simplement le
49-3 mais ça suppose qu'on passe par la
voie législative
là il s'agit donc effectivement donc
d'aller plus vite c'est l'ambition donc
du président de la république d'aller
plus vite pour réformer le code travail
et on sait que la procédure lice la team
se caractérise par sa longueur voire
parfois pas sa langue d'oc
il faut pour cela qu'il est quand même
la majorité dans le solage suppose
effectivement qu'il dispose d'une
majorité qui y croient
dévoué à l'assemblée nationale en tout
cas bertrand sassoye lubin est ce qu'on
pourra je reprenne au terme interne cher
aux basketteurs est-ce qu'on peut être
in et art à la fois
est-ce qu'on peut être par exemple
encarté dans une formation politique
est-il les républicains ou socialiste
est allé s'asseoir avec la république en
marche sous les ors de l'assemblée
nationale
c'est fort possible il faut possible et
puis a par ailleurs donc nous sommes
dans une période où je dirais les
idéologies sont mises à mal donc le la
république en marche voulant être un
mouvement ou encore un parti en courant
idéologique effectivement ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas nouveau on envie de dire il
y a déjà eu des précédents où
effectivement des gens bien qui tend
quand et ont pu se rallier à une
majorité pour des raisons diverses mais
il faudrait il qu'ils aillent s'asseoir
physiquement quelque part oui ça se sera
passé soit pas comme ces fameux ces
fameuses statistiques c'est chasser ces
schémas ses tableaux c'est ses
graphismes de la fiq avec des couleurs à
cherry pouvoir qu'on est là froid de ce
côté-là doué physiquement effectivement
peut-être qui se rassemblent tous deux
au même endroit droite dans l'assemblée
mais ce n'est pas dit non plus à partir
est bien on peut très bien participer à
cette majorité présidentielle sans être
physiquement
assis à côté de ceux qui se sont
manifestement ostensiblement positionné
en faveur de cette majorité
mais ce qui est surtout important dans
cette histoire
donc on a fait selon les prédictions
il y aurait quelque part un raz-de-marée
sur ce que je peux entendre alors que
hier pas plus tard au caire et ont un
raz-de-marée de la majorité des prisons
tiers mais la démocratie aussi suppose
qu'il y ait une opposition
alors on a parlé de cette élection de
samedi prochain et du week end après on
a parlé de cette convocation de la part
pour les députés pour qu'ils puissent
aller siéger léger à désigner leur
président à l'assemblée
entre temps qu'est ce que fait le député
qui viennent d'être élus
il attend patiemment cette convocation
où il celui déjà au travail
alors il attend la convocation allons
pas content ça c'est une des nouveautés
donc applicable à la froid suite pour
les élections présidentielles ce sera
aussi le cas pour ces élections
législatives c'est que une froid les
résultats proclamés d'accord dont le
nouvel élu est intronisé à l'homme la
deuxième étape c'est qu'il faut encore
attendre
effectivement donc la convocation
pour l'investiture je dirais plus ou
moins officielle donc de ses députés
alors ce qui va emporter une conséquence
majeure une nouveauté c'est que chacun
devra procéder à cette déclaration de sa
situation patrimoniale puisque s'il sait
trés issue donc des lois de 2013 entre
en application à l'occasion chacun devra
procéder à cette déclaration de sa
situation patrimoniale et les diplômes
en d'autres mots pour cela
avant avant notre fonction avant la
première séance des labels en train de
sa prise de fonction il doit dans les
deux mois faire procéder à cette
déclaration de situation patrimoniale
merci bertrand françois leblanc rappelle
que vous êtes universitaire y enseignant
en droit public
on rappelle que samedi des martiniquais
sont invités aux urnes pour désigner
leurs députés merci votre journée c'est
moi
[Musique]